[Music]
guys one time when I was in Las Vegas
I remember dears know that serendipity
restaurant yeah it is still there I
don't know I think I think I got
replaced by the Gordon Ramsay rest I
think you're right but back in the day
when I used to be there I remember I was
there and we were all eating some
burgers or something and then there was
this guy who had almost completely
finished his entire meal there was only
like a few bites left and he goes up to
the window or whatever it was like a
little walk-up window he walks up and
he's demanding for a refund because it
was disgusting and I'm like but dude you
ate the whole thing but they still gave
him a refund what asian asian Chinese
Vietnamese Chinese Gordon Ramsay my
people Gordon Ramsay not your people
why go on Ramsay's like [ __ ] you know
serendipity all right sir roll I kinda
understand that because I used to go to
a wing night at big wings and we I love
big wings like they made the best wings
but then on wing night they were like 50
cent were there like really cheap wings
I think they're 50 cent wings or
something like that I can't remember the
deal there were tracks wings yeah but
yeah there were way lower quality but I
would keep eating them thinking that
maybe get better like this flavor and
then I get pissed at the end because I
ate so many you know I really wanted a
refund did you ask for it though after I
mean I didn't ask cuz I would take
responsibility for my own actions cuz
you're not an [ __ ] I think most
people would just like either
immediately return it or just live with
the fact that you ate it alright I will
say on the rare occasion sometimes I
beaten it and it's just not good and
then the waitress never comes back and
everyone else is eating so I'll just
kind of keep nibbling on it and then I'm
like out of crossroads when she finally
comes back she's a good evening okay and
I'm like actually Vicky and then like
sometimes if she pushes me I'll be like
actually like this is wrong with it and
like send it back but you know I can
understand that
I've never said pull back but I've
definitely taken Cologne back to Sephora
mmm they'll take it back like long is
this like a corner left in there
don't take anything I have to take
anything back like literally I've went
to a whole bottle was like I need this
again let me take it back and get it
together dude wait so if you take it
back you're like hey this cool clone
sucks let me get the same one there's
like yeah I've been wearing this for
lawanna and I didn't realize that this
was the reason that I call a ranch every
time I was wearing it and so no no I'll
just get the money back and I'll go to a
different store and buy the things did
you act it did you have to bring them a
receipt no Sephora will take anything
back where I know you think Nordstrom
well I have a perfume that has been
giving me confusion migraines
I am literally Psyduck to Sephora so let
me teach you something what I used to
date a guy who works in luggage if you
go by your handout I'm sorry I used to
teach a guy who I said luxury and if
what is that is that a place Gucci okay
okay guys so if you uh bring something
in like a purse or something and the
reason for returning it is medical
like this gives me a back egg like it
hurts my shoulders and whatever they
technically have to take it back and
fake it they can't ask questions and
they can't get like proof from a doctor
anything if it's like a medical thing so
try it dude I move it I'm literally
dying like what did you get it from I
got it from Nordstrom and I bought like
a $200 set of this really nice Chanel
perfume yeah that's talk about
immediately afterwards so I started like
I would just have confusion for like
three or four hours so if you guys ever
had just confusion that's my whole life
yeah pretty much my only other common
clarity after you come no like headache
I go hard in the paint that's true I've
had I've actually heard what happened I
remember that yeah
I play waka pakka flame hold on the
whole light because on repeat but all
the 30 minutes if I was about to get
like thrown down by a guy and he was
putting on Walker [ __ ] man it's pray
that a bad data on I put on some Jordan
this is the steady rhythm the whole time
proof you got receipts yeah I got
receipts like imagine a walk a flock in
him putting a headband on and I'm like I
am curiously around it's better than a
guy put on music a dressing like the
Mark of Zorro honestly both so what
happened I think that okay one more plug
if you tell them that you really want to
turn it and they don't give you a
[ __ ] and they giving you [ __ ] for it
would be like call corporate right now
and then they'll most likely corpora
will be like no just give it to them
I've learned a lot during that time yeah
I'm dating a lawyer good that's it okay
well this story here oh [ __ ] we adenine
got two what's his story
we have it's idiot so Monique she went
to a Philly cheesesteak location in
Stockton around 7:40 Monday night more
Cal and Filipinos she had eaten the
sandwich like halfway through half of
her sandwich half of the fries and
that's when she or two sandwiches and
that's when she wanted to get a refund
but once the people there they were like
okay well we'll give you your refund
will replace what's wrong with Abel we
need the sandwich back and I guess or
like the food back and she didn't want
to give the food so she ended up going
crazy on him and she did this mmm public
freak-outs public freak-outs let's go
this is this is Monique right Monique
Monique make the celebrity no no no dude
I thought you might Monique the
celebrity you know like I believe this
let me see I believe it too after she
won the Oscar she did certainly in
theater what was that show in the 90s
Monique Monique Brandi played it girl
the big lady right yeah that's what I'm
thinkin oh oh yeah
Brande Brande play Moesha Moesha what
your kids oh I am cute little bit racist
but I'm started with the same letters
yeah here we go
so she's demanding a refund they say
give him back the food no she took a tip
jar she threw the tip jar at them and
then that's when the owner comes out
[Applause]
[Music]
this lady's iron about soccer nails
are you really willing to catch a case
for a [ __ ] sandwich like six months
Jamie it's the principal you ain't
happening
I said no mayo this lady got cheated on
and she was just looking for an excuse
to take it out on someone this is about
something everybody throws chairs
doesn't care about the quality of life
that's what i'ma say a couple of chairs
I'll respect their privacy one time I
had a I used to work in a bar it works
in a TGI Fridays I need to know what's
going on because there's some giggles
and I'm gonna find out no I
there was a lady I got thrown there was
some there were gang members right and
they got mad because at 155 we had to
take their glasses away because though
yeah yes and they refused and so first
they throw the beer mug at me all our
broth they take yeah they take a chair
and they throw it at one of the
bartender's these dudes are chicks these
are dudes she's severely injured and
she's out for a week
oh my weeks later the detective comes to
Friday's and he's like man would you be
willing to testify and I was like
absolutely [ __ ] not like their gang
McMurphy yeah like you're not gonna get
me [ __ ] killed but you want me
standing up a court looking at him like
yes that's the man right there that did
it and I'm like I'm gonna be okay after
he gets out oh no
they see the cool thing were they're
like hey we could put you in witness
protection
no not for gang members plastic surgery
what was this that was
this is Virginia oh I'm obsessed by
everybody do a charity yeah you do the
Roanoke gangs man the Roanoke games are
serious I snitch hold snitches get
stitches [ __ ] don't do [ __ ] around me I
am coming to court and I'm pointing it
out you never seen the kid you never see
the Jamestown gangs man I don't care
about you heard me talk about my
motherly hips I'm not going to jail for
no [ __ ] body I'm selling on everybody
you're perfect now I'm telling and I'm
giving y'all recipe so he did it you
know why cuz I ever heard of the
Richmond boys okay I just want to say I
hate when people do the whole stitches
and snitches get stitches thing when
you're [ __ ] like 20 year old Asian
guys still living with your [ __ ]
grandparents and they pay for your bills
and [ __ ] and you're not you're not about
that life at all I just got really
gangsta way of saying please don't tell
on me don't do [ __ ] in front of me what
are you gonna do blow your vape smoke in
my face smell cute I'll make it very
known that I'm not built for jail so
don't do [ __ ] in front of me don't have
me in the car when I'm at work
every riding on these fools drop me off
first and don't tell me what you riding
on sad fools ass because I'm going to
tell auntie if it's not a crime can you
keep a secret
I'm a great secret keeper yeah I am but
a crime no I'm very sure that you
wouldn't you wouldn't roll why because
I'm lat no cuz I thought that you're a
good good dude who doesn't roll on his
friends doesn't transfer on I don't love
is you don't do anything illegal Knapp
is white-collar crime I'll keep that to
myself you'd like cheating on the taxes
and [ __ ] like babe yeah I got no worry
about that so you can get paid for that
now if you just report people to the
iron I don't know about
you never you never heard the
white-collar crime saying snitches get
you know months in jail did you play
tennis and Jeff tax season is coming up
sounds like someone who also is
committing these white-collar crimes
like what that he goes to mirror cheater
jacks or something real light like that
that ain't nothin that's his getting
back what's yours the government I can
take a suit out of your pocket like like
they helped you come up with these
designs a lot of [ __ ] I talked to me
for these shirts got a paper none of
these designs or taxation is theft there
you go that's too mean well how can we
tell gonna be no taxation without
representation if the person I voted for
didn't get elected I don't have
representation Slauson me in tax kind of
[ __ ] the Wesley Snipes try dude is did
you follow all that well Wesley Snipes
did it on a much larger still I'm making
a couple thousand dollars he's making a
couple million
he did it great though here's no
representation for independent
contractors we just get [ __ ] up the
ass ah man I just I just keep little
women I keep Lulu because everyone on
their on their list they got horse
around my name and the IRS that's all
we're gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of there
waiting to April 14th and [ __ ] 12 59
59 before I'm sayin saying like because
she made a joke that was cute too here
lays in bed dims the lights on April
14th of midnight I guess he leaves the
door unlocked for the IRS lay on my
stomach I have some loot scented candles
going oh my god no this is gonna hurt
haven't seen him in a while so on the
list where would you put the IRS is
ranking wise great question well
obviously gonna be higher than a 7
because they always go wrong when you
think of do he always tears a little oh
I can't see it for weeks
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]